to leave in like 15 minutes so I want to
extract much as from Heather as possible
Heather when you do land Your Man
what percentage of the bills are you
going to take care of
well I think it depends so if I'm the
stay-at-home wife if we have kids then
he would be taking care of 100 of the
bills okay so ideally
he's paying everything okay and how much
should your monthly allowance be
creation what it takes to
stay fit and stay looking good and you
keep the guy that looks like that so I
mean you know so how much I don't I
don't have a number exactly hair nails
clothes gym membership gym membership
fatty looking good fit clothes savings
what's your monthly allowance that the
the rich dude who's wiping you up
wouldn't need to give you there's a
number in mind right
I don't have a number in mind but think
of a number no I don't know I keep
throwing out what's 10 grand a month
perfect so you're gonna get 120 Grand a
year just to be hot and cool yeah
to raise the kids to raise the family
all right what's your monthly allowance
by the way
um
I have a trust fund
no wonder you only wanted to do to make
70k because Daddy's got to go in home
Okay no Okay in all seriousness
um like
I feel like with rent included I usually
spend like 5K or less a month yes okay
so that should be your allowance to stay
home
well that I mean that would include like
rent and stuff so oh no if rent's taken
care of your car is taken care of your
bills are taken care of this is just
I need to spend some money because it
does cost a lot more money
to be a woman than a man what do I mean
by that I should know from a man
you need to pay I'm not talking about
rent bills you know Insurance like basic
type stuff I'm talking about like upkeep
like today I [__] got out of the
shower threw some clothes on I'm out
boom you had to do your hair your makeup
you had to make sure that everything is
good your mascara by the way you're
killing it uh I mean it costs a lot more
money to be a chick right but I mean in
that sense if we're talking you know the
car is paid rents paid all that then I
mean I mean 10 grand that's that's a lot
I could spend 10 grand a month but
people think about all of that every
year you invest in in that what if
something goes wrong and you've had you
have a low allowance you don't have as
much savings and then you're starting
over from square one I'd want like
contingency where I'm like every year it
goes up for every year I'm investing in
you you invest a little more in me and
that way if we both it's called cost of
living increase and that's exactly what
happens in Social Security that's
exactly what happened we're familiar
with inflation not a bad move by James
can I ask you a question yeah go for it
what would be reasonable to you
simply tickle out of those boxes yeah
well I've done this before yeah so what
experience because I'd imagine if you
say too high of the numbers that are red
flag to a guy or no of course it's a two
hour number keep in mind I'm not making
10 million dollars a year okay I'm
making well over six figures
um
when I was with
a girl that lived with me for a while I
said
um
rents paid bills are paid I'm taking
care of food groceries literally you
have no expenses here's a car I hope you
like Alexis boom you you got nothing to
do and here's and then she negotiated
she's like because I didn't know at the
time I'm like everything's free
congratulations and she goes well what
about everything else I was like well
what do you mean and this is where I
learned about women hair clothes Nails
makeup Manny's patties spray tans this
that the other and I go how much do you
want a month she goes
how much is your hair how much is hair
as a girl 500 bucks yeah yeah
I was on a straight Fade with homie
Rodrigo what
it okay this is crazy this is what I'm
saying this is reality and by the way
the hotter and sexier girl the more you
gotta pay yeah that's how it works yeah
oh you want some hussy from the streets
yeah give her 50 bucks a month you're
Gucci You Want To Miss USA contestant
she's asking for 10K a month you got a
shoe for the stars and yeah you reach
the ceiling no what's what's the saying
shoot for the moon and if you miss you
still end up going to start or something
like that that's what delusional is
inside swing low you know okay
um but speaking of upkeep I do have to
go to my boxing class yeah so okay last
question for you because I know you got
to go then we're gonna do a super chat
and then Natalia is going to take your
seat so I don't know if anyone's gonna
take Natalia's seat over there but
um
last question and then we'll open up to
the panels you meet this dude amazing
he's the man he's doing it not ideally
realistically how much should he spend
on your engagement ring oh that's a
question
isn't there like an like statistic it
should be like the third of his paycheck
or something like a third of two or
three months
without doing like you know long
division just give me a number he should
spend on an engagement ring you know
numbers
[Laughter]
I don't I don't know
someone else go first and then we'll go
from there 50k 50k okay I don't even
know what a 50k ring that's a lot my
friend has a ring that's like 100k God
damn it got one friend that married that
one dude okay down the line here how
much should your man spend on an
engagement ring I don't know um I've
literally never thought about that
question
um
five okay I wouldn't necessarily put a
number because it depends on what level
of man that you're dating how much
they're making I would say
don't embarrass me because there are
some rings like I've gotten a necklace
from a guy he's like like uh Happy
Valentine's Day and I looked at it I'm
like did you get this for 59 at Macy's
like I could tell like where it was from
and like the quality but for me
personally I don't even need a diamond
because I lose don't embarrass I'm like
get me a really pretty ring that looks
expensive that maybe not it like isn't
breaking them Emily how much
um I just want to Purl honestly that
that's all I want so however a nice
Pearl is that's what I'll take well just
we've got one right here
[Music]
right on your finger rock around with
that for a little while now when you
meet the man of your dreams I know guys
are sliding in that DM left and right
these days how much you want him to
spend on the engagement right like a 50
Grand right I think
I mean I you know as you get married you
can upgrade your ring um
would be a good starting like minimum
let me tell you guys a story and then
I'm going to read some stats okay so
there the girl that was getting her
allowance that we're talking about right
there it was time to get her a ring we
got engaged we didn't end up getting
married or whatever
and
be very careful the type of women that
you bring your girl around I'll say that
again be very careful Gentlemen of the
type of women you bring your girl around
so here I am I'm dating this young girl
she's 10 years younger than me I think I
was 33 at the time she was 23. I'm
bringing her around all my successful
friends and their wives and they're like
I've got this I've got this handbag I've
got this I've got this handbag and these
girls starts getting speaking of
delusional delusions of grandeur so
let's say I'm making at the time a
quarter million or a half a million
dollars a year good money for a dude but
my boys are making
Millions 10 Millions they're the biggest
hotel nightlife guys in all of Miami and
these are the dinner tables and these
are the the women that are surrounding
my girl so here's my girl who was broke
as [__] just graduated college 22. now
she's 23 and she's like yeah well like
so and so has a ten thousand dollar bag
so that's kind of what I want and
so-and-so has a hundred thousand dollar
ring so this is kind of where I'm at I'm
like you are homeless and hungry when I
met you baby
that's why it's so very careful that's
why it's so important to make sure
you're choosing the right woman because
if it was the right woman for you and
clearly it wasn't because you guys broke
up she would have wanted to build your
Empire and work with you to make sure
that she wasn't trying to make you go
broke with materialistic I have a
question let me let me just let me do
this I agree with you what but here's
why I disagree with you because no
matter what that girl's mindset is no
matter how much you can train her or
educate you
women are very impressionable and if
she's the one girl with a what's a Kate
Spade bag and all her friends have Louis
Vuitton bags she's gonna be like oh
you're that [__] okay got it yeah
you're the broker and like women are
emotional and then she's gonna come home
and be like why don't I have the
Balenciaga bag or whatever and I'm like
because they're child rapist that's why
but you know
but these are the types of things that
that men need to understand when you're
bringing you so now when I meet a girl
I'm like yeah I mean any of my rich
friends wives like you're meeting all my
broke friends
you're me and all my I'm the richest one
of my friends all my friends are brokeys
you're lucky you have a roof over your
head and that's how you get to the right
mindset I feel like this is why a lot of
guys are opting out of marriage today is
because they're like okay you want this
expensive ass ring and then I gotta pay
for this expensive ass wedding forget
the milk that I already get for free
because Heather has to go by the way
just so we got this here uh how much did
you spend on your engagement ring the
average cost that a guy spends six grand
by the way
how much does the average girl
and when she proposes to a man what do
you think oh that happened
trick question girls don't do that yeah
okay so just keep that in mind ladies
that the man is the one that has to
spend this type of money by the way what
percentage of men
spend over ten thousand dollars on an
engagement ring what percentage of men
spend over 10 grand so by the way when I
bought a ring for my girl at the time 25
Grand I spent what I got it back and
then the economy hit was it was an issue
I think I got like 12 for it [__] up
what percentage of men
uh we'll spend over 10K go
five five eight eight
twelve twelve ten ten nine seven and
that's the winner winner chicken dinner
so just ladies out there gentlemen out
there we talk about idealistically and
then realistically most men are not
making six figures only 13 of them most
men are not spending more than ten Grand
to buy an engagement ring only seven
percent most men make 38k a year guys if
you want hotter better classier Doper
women you gotta make more money because
they got demands with that being said
this beautiful girl has to leave right
now Heather clap it up for Heather
ladies and gentlemen right there okay
you want to just exit stages
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible